[Music]
Kota coffee adopts of baby girl the 53
year old Today Show co-anchor made the
announcement on Tuesday show over the
phone I do have something to tell you
but you know what how about this instead
of telling you I'm going to show you
something
all right Jimmy game you have a picture
you can put up for me little girl
hailey joy I adopted her and you can
hear that surprise hailey if she
wouldn't she's a Valentine's baby not
good she's tiny when I got her and she's
the love of my life several members of
HOTAS Today Show family have tweeted
their congrats including Savannah
Guthrie Jenna Bush Hager and Kathie Lee
Gifford who wrote so thrilled for Hoda
and her precious daughter hailey joy she
will be the best mommy ever
we love you Hoda enjoy every moment this
is HOTAS first child she's dating
financier Joel Schiffman but did not
mention him during her adoption
announcement one fun fact check out
these recent posts from HOTAS Instagram
she definitely had been hinting that
something new and exciting was coming
this one reads for all the things my
hands have hell's the best by far
is you
you
[Music]